who when was your first cigarette do you
remember it yeah I remember it really
well yeah it was delicious and my father
smoked and was very he smoked unfiltered
cigarettes called pel mels he called
them pel mels oh yeah palmals but they
were extra long flavored with licorice I
think made by the American Tobacco
Company great cigarette in a red pack
and we had many so that's I don't even
know if there's a picture of the he
smoked right there right there one down
one down that right there that's the
cigarette of my childhood he picked him
up in the Marine Corps when he was 17 I
guess they came in his KRA and that that
was the cigarette of my childhood and
there was always one smoldering in an
ashtray in her kitchen and everywhere
else anyway but I was I was like when I
was little I was against it and my
father really loved cigarettes and he
wasn't embarrassed of it it wasn't like
I smoke but I feel bad about it he was
like No And I smoke unfiltered because
you feel stripping when you're done
there's no filter you smoke them
backwards so the enemy doesn't know it's
an American cigarette you burn the logo
off the off the paper
ah he yeah he really lik cigarettes and
he felt sorry for people who didn't
smoke so I was like maybe 13 I was in
e8th grade when I started and yeah it
was it was totally where were you were
you out with the boys or you was at the
house and you smok was at school I was
at school smoked one at school oh yeah
it was loud actually it was a pretty
freaky with a teacher I know it sounds
like it was in the 18 sounds romantic I
think it was romantic it was great just
a sneak it sounds like Espionage no no
no it was totally open you could smoke
at school I could smoke at school
through senior year of high school oh
yeah no oh yeah you could smoke as a
child at school oh yeah I had parental
permission yeah really I shouldn't be
saying this it's you know what's so
funny people would be like yeah I did
iar DMT and everyone's like it's so cool
it's like yeah I smoked a
cigarette what you're a
criminal um but you know I mean I mean I
I don't I wouldn't I wouldn't say
smoking is a great long-term play yeah I
don't think that it is it where I quit
when I was 45 cuz I felt like I probably
should yeah it'll probably get me anyway
but I did enjoy it I really did I never
had a bad one you know yeah there are no
bad cigarettes you're not like oh this
is disgusting I never felt that way at
all oh wow yeah I've had bad Fig Newtons
like you can screw up almost any
consumer product but a cigarette is
remarkably
consistent and it gives you what it
promises you the payoff is always there
that's a good point yeah the payoff is
always there you know especially that
first [__] drag off that in the
morning in the morning you know what I
loved was they had a man in our area and
um uh it was actually my grandmother was
uh married to a man and he would light
his cigarette and he would let us inhale
the lit the smoke up our nose when we
were really young Louisiana's the best
isn't it God it was [__] good I think
it's got the the highest smoking rate of
any state you makeing me nervous I'm
going to grab another Zen you mind one
in I'm going to God I almost want to do
one but I just don't know how I'll do
with it why don't we wait until we're
about to close cuz things may happen to
you that you're not ready for okay but
it gets wild huh it gets wild in a
subtle way it kind of grows on you it's
not it's not like doing cocaine okay
it's not like firing up the pipe and
yeah you know what I mean blast off or
anything like that it's a much more
subtle organic you just all of a sudden
you feel good yeah then you feel the
power rising from your central nervous
system then sort of going outward
through all the nerve endings down to
the tips of your fingers and then up
here it just starts crackling the
synapses damn just make connections that
you hadn't before I know I'm making it
sound like iasa it's a lot more subtle
than that once you try this you're going
to get a lot richer Zen is that their
advertising campaign Zen is not a sin
that's the advertising campaign really
yeah but the truth is Zen is a powerful
work enhancer and also a male enhancer
if you know what I mean really yeah
talking erection huh yep there's no
election for it with Zen
wow I don't know if I want a Zen
supported wiener you know I don't know I
think you do I think you you think so oh
yeah because you want people to get
addicted to Just Close Your
Eyes oh damn it's like that that's the
neighbor saying hey it's real quiet over
there just whack it on the
[Music]
nightstand ah sorry excuse me sorry tuck
if you did like a tuck or a lip Tucker
yeah I would if that was your brand of
of nicotine do that because I believe in
it tuck Tucka tuck yeah tuck tuck and
you could have a Native American
attached to it I love that I definitely
get picketed but I do it anyway yeah but
some of love it Native Americans love
nicotine dude they certainly do God they
love it and I unlike most people I
actually know some do you I yes I do I
because I live near I I live near a a
population of Native Americans in Maine
in Maine and employe too and have for
years and they're really wonderful
people spent a lot of time with them and
uh they the two that I know very well
both love tobacco and they have every
right to yeah look I think it let them
love it you know at least leave them
with tobacco you know after everything
that happened to well they actually they
gave us tobacco they did 100% wow yeah
it was I mean there are a million
different Native Americans it's one of
those terms it's like I'm not sure what
pasam aquatis have to do with hopes like
it's pretty you know there was a lot of
beef there was a lot of beef between
native like different Indian tribes oh
yeah yeah some of them were very warlike
I think is the term we use but um no
they used a lot of tribes used it in in
uh religious rituals and they would they
would they would use it rect uhh really
yeah tobacco
suppositories yeah there's a ram R get
it up there oh dang huh yeah for real
look it
up boof and freaking that's insane what
I I can't did Indian yeah let's see
tobacco smoke in them let's see oh there
you go oh yeah look at that okay so that
said was used by okay imported from the
new
world okay and an insu an insufflation
of tobacco smoke into the rectum by
animal was a medical treatment employed
by the European Physicians right but
also it says uh tobacco smoke was used
by Western Metal uh as a tool against
cold and drowsiness and drowsiness [__]
if you're if I'm drowsy and you're
blowing smoke in my ass I'm at the I got
a wrong po you definitely do and by the
way it's not even covered now yeah crazy
no no that that and leeches are like
completely ignored by the medical
establishment but um yeah it was it was
common the procedure was used to treat
gut pain and attempts were often made
I'm not making this up you're
factchecking me in real time no I love
this but applying it by animal was a
technique appropriator from the North
American indigenous people yes that's
right wow see how great is that that's
amazing that they even thought it up I
think but if you're chilling around that
long you got somebody's going to blow
smoke in somebody's
ass you think so yeah yeah dude you get
people around so like how many thousands
of years does it take in The
evolutionary process for someone to say
okay we've reached this point in
Civilization where somebody's got to
blow smoke up someone else's
ass is that before or after the wheel
cuz they never figured out the wheel
yeah look I think it's four years
somebody's blow smokeing really it's
quick it's quick
yeah